[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my new Fantastic Four Doctor
Doom video apparently Marvel was ready
to cast Robert Downey Jr as a version of
Doctor Doom so we'll break it all down
because it's a really cool reveal from
Kevin feige and John Favreau if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because
there are a lot of deleted scenes and
Easter eggs featuring The Doctor Doom
character in the newer Marvel movies
that I'll point out too should we talk
about that because I think that's
probably one of the greatest decisions
in the history of of Hollywood Robert
had come in for a general on it and I
remember you had all met with him
already for like Dr Doom or something on
another project I think on on on I think
he had come through on a pre like maybe
Fantastic Four right everybody has good
days and bad days and I remember on
later movies we'll talk about a 15th
anniversary of those there were dark
days and I would say Robert we wouldn't
be in this mess it wasn't for you
meaning we wouldn't have a studio if it
wasn't for it's true or you tell me your
memories of of where that idea came from
because there was some other people so
everybody sort of knew who he was and I
I remember sitting down with the guy and
I was like geez he just got it and he's
got that spark in him and his eye and
he's ready and that's when we were in
your office and and we were pointing to
his headshot and saying we got to try to
figure this out the way they talk about
it he was going up for Doctor Doom
during the original Fantastic Four movie
and that would have been around 2003
2004 when they were casting that role
when he was in the middle of making Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang with Shane black who they
would later hire to direct Iron Man 3.
and originally there was an earlier
version of that first Iron Man movie
that they tried to make with Tom Cruise
is Iron Man Tony Stark which is why they
were all those Doctor Strange two Iron
Man Tom Cruise rumors like oh he's
coming back around like they were paying
off this Easter egg that didn't wind up
working out when they originally thought
to make him a version of Iron Man in the
MCU the other funny thing about that
original Fantastic Four movie is that
mass Mickelson auditioned for Reed
Richards but lost out to Joan gruffit
think about all the really dark
characters that he's played since then
like he'd be perfect Doctor Doom let me
know what you think about the idea of
Robert Danny Jr playing a version of
Doctor Doom I feel like he could pull it
off just because he's a fantastic actor
but his version of Doctor Doom would
probably be a little more unhinged like
he's got that crazy energy about him
that's in the Tony Stark character
especially early on before he matures a
little bit over the course of the
infinity Saga right now we have
spider-verse coming out it's a big
Multiverse movie we have a Multiverse
Saga happening right now maybe someday
we'll see Multiverse versions of Doctor
Doom played by mass Mickelson and Robert
Downey Jr speaking of which I'm giving
away spider-verse tickets to just random
people in the comments of this video and
thank you to private internet access VPN
for sponsoring this week's giveaway a
VPN is a tool that hides your IP address
and safeguards your internet connection
through an encrypted tunnel it also
allows you to change your online geo
location normally on my Marvel or DC
videos I do giveaways for Disney Plus or
HBO Max subscriptions or Netflix
subscriptions but some of you probably
live in countries that don't have access
to those streaming services or episodes
get locked in something we like to call
Netflix Alex jail were the only
available in certain countries but with
private internet access VPN you can
actually change the location you access
content online from so even if you live
outside the United States or North
America just download private internet
access connect to a us or UK server and
you'll get anything that they're
blocking in your country they even give
it a huge shout out during Spider-Man
far from home by the way travel tip you
should probably download a VPN on your
phone just so that the government can
track you while we're abroad smart
she's not wrong you can also use the VPN
to stop anyone from snooping on your
browsing history that was even a major
plot point during the Hawkeye series and
right now they're giving away the
service at an 83 percent discount all
you have to do is use my link in the
description I'll put it on screen here
too and you get an extra four months for
free they do have a 30-day refund policy
too if you decide it's not for you that
works out to about two dollars and three
cents a month to protect an unlimited
amount of devices that you own and
there's no limit on the number of people
who can get the deal so everyone
watching the video can claim it so be
sure to check it out they're in the
middle of casting the new versions of
the Fantastic Four MCU actors right now
we just saw John Krasinski and Doctor
Strange 2 as the 838 Universe version of
the character so we've already started
to see Fantastic Four stuff in the
background of the MCU reportedly we're
not supposed to see the MCU version of
Dr Doom though for a couple more years
at least like there might be some
references to him during this new
Fantastic Four movie but he's not
supposed to be a big character during
that reportedly they're going to use
Galactus as a big one the scale is again
in
that all is as it was perfectly balanced
this whole thing should be it is known
by many names why people called it
Galactus
the Devourer of Worlds and it'll
actually be terrax that will be his
Herald not Silver Surfer so also be a
little bit longer before we actually see
Silver Surfer in the MCU there have been
a couple deleted scenes in Easter eggs
for Doctor Doom in the newer Marvel
movies though probably the biggest one
was during Doctor Strange Multiverse of
Madness because the director Sam Raimi
the writer specifically talked about the
Doctor Doom character when they were
writing parts of the movie the detail of
the teleportation device he uses to get
into the scene is something we took from
the comics that's Dr Tunes Dr Doom's uh
time door what they're talking about is
actually right out of the comics the
whole idea is that Kang basically finds
Dr Doom's Museum in an old doombot and
takes his technology to create his first
time travel device taking it back in
time to ancient Egypt to become the Rama
Tut version of Kang which we saw
recently during Ant-Man the WASP Quantum
Mania that's meant to be him at the
beginning of his timeline eventually the
Fantastic Four found out what he was
doing because it was happening in a
Fantastic Four comic book one of the
earliest ones they go back stop him and
he escapes to the Future to become king
the Conqueror like he changes his name
to Kang then keeps coming back to fight
The Avengers through different parts of
the timeline you're an Avenger have I
killed you before they all blow together
after a while you're not the one with
the hammer it's Thor so in the 838
Universe there is a version of Doctor
Doom that's active in this universe they
just didn't cast an actor to play him in
the movie one of the kings in the
background here during Ant-Man the
wasp's quantumania post credit scene is
also the Doctor Doom version of Kang so
they're actually two different versions
of Dr Doom Kang one is Doctor Doom
becoming a version of Kang and the other
is Kang pretending to be Doctor Doom
this is just meant to be a version of
Kang in an alternate universe that's
pretending to be doctored him which is
why his armor looks like doctor Doom's
armor the version of Doctor Doom that
becomes a version of Kang is called Doom
the annihilating Conqueror that's more
like Dune taking the powers of Kang
during black panther wakanda forever
which takes place in the MCU a big plot
point is the other nations of the world
searching for vibranium at the beginning
of the movie originally Lake Bell's
character was supposed to be a version
of Lucia Von Barta who's one of Dr
Doom's underlings from lot varia and she
was going to secretly be working for for
him to find that underwater vibranium so
Dr Doom is looking for vibranium in the
MCU also during the Moon Knight series
when he winds up in that foreign country
in the background there is a castle that
looks just like the castles of lot varia
and the writers also specifically said
that was meant to be an Easter egg like
yeah he's probably in a version of lot
very when he's waking up here you can
let me know who you want to play that
new MCU version of Doctor Doom but there
are also lots of Easter eggs for Robert
Downey Jr showing up in future Marvel
movies as other characters or other
versions of characters too deleted
scenes from previous movies and Easter
eggs there was a deleted scene from
Avengers Infinity War where he briefly
becomes sorcerer Supreme rescuing Dr
Strange and Doctor Strange also becomes
the iron Mage wearing his Iron Man armor
there are also newer rumors about Robert
Downey Jr now coming back as a version
of that Superior Iron Man of the 838
universe that they didn't wind up
casting an actor for in Doctor Strange 2
trying to get revenge for Scarlet Witch
killing the Illuminati maybe we'll see a
version of that during a Avengers 5 King
Dynasty or like some small Easter egg
because there are rumors that part of
Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 will borrow
from the plot of Avengers forever which
involves a version of Kang using an evil
Avengers team from Another Universe to
fight the good Avengers so during King
Dynasty we could see some of these
actors come back as The Avengers but as
alternate universe versions that are
evil fighting the new Avengers then a
lot of other cool details that Kevin
feige and John Favreau talk about with
Robert Downey Jr just the history of the
MCU a big part of his process when they
were making the first Iron Man movie
Robert Downey Jr's was rewriting the
script every day with the director of
the other creatives just to make
whatever they were shooting the next day
even better and one of the big tipping
points that they credit is the original
Comic-Con event in 2007 where they
showed off the first trailer but also
before that Kevin feige actually did a
Comic-Con panel where he specifically
called out that they were making the
Avengers like oh we're making a Captain
America movie we're doing a Thor movie
we're doing an Incredible Hulk movie and
they're all gonna meet up and cross over
in The Avengers
so even before the first Iron Man movie
was released the MCU had already started
to take shape and the whole MCU of it
all was one of the reasons why fans were
even more hyped especially long-term
comic book fans like oh they're all
connected all these things are going to
cross over and we're going to build up
to something even bigger the whole Grand
Design of it which was Thanos The
Infinity Gauntlet Avengers Infinity war
and Avengers end game and now I'm
actually kind of glad that Robert Downey
Jr wasn't that original Dr Doom in the
original Fantastic Four movies because
even though they have their moments like
they're a couple good moments in there
generally those original Fantastic Four
movies aren't that great and even Kevin
feige and John Favreau now talk about
Robert Downey Jr being cast as Iron Man
being one of the greatest things to ever
happen in the history of Hollywood like
one of the most fantastic pairings of an
actor and a character you almost can't
imagine him playing any other characters
the other funny thing too is when they
start talking about Samuel L Jackson as
Nick Fury they said that behind the
scenes they think of him as Gandalf or
at the time they thought of him as
Gandalf a character that just shows up
out of nowhere when you need him and
helps you and then disappears he then
described him as we were going forward
as Gandalf that he would appear when
needed with answers and I always thought
that was very smart idea for for Fury
suggested the all the way at the end of
the credit area remember when we showed
it to him at Scott Walker it was it was
just after the first few credits he's
like he's like the whole end yeah Ferris
Bueller style yes there's also a funny
connection to the Deadpool movies too
like we're making Deadpool 3 right now
they literally just started filming it
Kevin feige refers to that original Iron
Man post-credits scene as pulling a
Ferris Bueller putting it at the very
end of the credits and during the first
Deadpool movie they specifically
parodied that Ferris Bueller post credit
scene but in a much more literal way in
related Fantastic Four news we will hear
confirmations about who some of the
major characters are really soon we
probably won't find out who's gonna play
that new Doctor Doom for a couple more
years though speaking of Nick Fury click
here for my brand new secret Invasion
trailer video in Easter eggs and click
here for my brand new Captain America 4
for First Look breakdown in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]